foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
for two
Rebels with a Cause
[Applause]
[Music]
the rebels were the cause Comedy Tour
tickets on sale now at louder with
crowder.com tour
isn't it wonderful
in all the years we've been married
we've done some marvelous things this
however
truly a miracle thank you nama
whatever whatever your name Mrs Noah I
love you Mrs Noah and I love you oh
shall we yes
[Applause]
oh boy
that
is a lot of [ __ ]
I'm leaving you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that's a few pounds heavier sip for all
of us after Thanksgiving we're tired
yeah I'm getting someone in my left
headphone uh yeah we all put on a few
you're getting tired you're not tired
you slept well from Turkey it always
makes you tired remember that's not true
that's a myth uh glad to be with you
after Thanksgiving hope you had a good
Thanksgiving did you have a good
Thanksgiving and comment below if you
did at this point it doesn't really
matter but you know you can all Talk
Amongst yourselves
we have a lot to get to today first off
let's start with us Alyssa Milano uh is
a Nazi to begin with
facts
we'll be talking about what's uh what's
going on in China a few reasons that
this matters I know you're saying well
I've heard about this I know you may not
really know the ins and outs also it
relates to you more than you may think
and for that we'll actually go to the
north of our border Canada to sort of
see some of these striking similarities
they're terrifying
um equally racist uh we'll also be
talking about Disney Disney's been
flopping I don't know if you know this
there's some big wins Silver Linings
here the woke film's not doing all that
well and
gosh this just since we did we haven't
been here since last Tuesday uh fauci's
Gone
wow yeah yeah so we've got a time to
close on the fauci so there's a lot to
get to there are a lot of wins to
celebrate he'll never really go away no
he'll never go away he'll never go away
especially if he you know gets wetter
you feed him after midnight it's like a
genital wart yes do those not go away I
think you can get them burned off but
they're there forever friend my doctor's
a horrible liar all right Gerald hey how
are you sir how are you was your
Thanksgiving okay it was good yeah
that's why I got some rest which I
needed yeah I ate some food I got some
sleep yeah we had ham we had smoked
turkey and smoke I don't know like I
don't like we talked about this we don't
I don't like turkey that much
it I realize now after having had a
smoked turkey or if you have a fried
turkey I feel like people have just been
screwing with me my whole life like
having me eat that dog crap that was
normal turkey when this was always
available like I ate it and this is so
much better that it makes me mad yeah
did you feel that the first time you ate
non-oven turkey you're like this this
was an option yeah first smoked turkey
was the best ugh it's like fried chicken
you're like what what is this what is
this why is it so much greater I've been
eating dog food all this time makes no
sense when I could have eaten this like
it's not as good for you you're like but
who cares it's emotionally better for me
what am I retired
and you know him you love him the
fastest man on his feet uh we have
tickets only tickets left are at the one
show in Baltimore this week in December
3rd it's the last leg of the tour go to
ladderscrutter.com tour four tickets
Baltimore Maryland December 3rd Dave
Landau how are you sir Ahoy coming to
you Omar I'm good oh wait what from The
Wire oh
wow never watched The Wire I tried to I
couldn't get into it you got to pass
season one season one you're like why is
this law in order and then it takes off
oh does it okay that was sort of like Oz
I'm like ah how many sodomy scenes do
you need pretty much that stays the same
does it yeah yes one more it's a
constant yeah it's pretty much just JK
Rowling he's just having sex with men
that was the inspiration JK Simmons I
thought it was weird that the warden was
named Dumbledore
[Laughter]
broomsticks oh God Slytherin
he does slither in yes it makes sense
now
before I move on here to Alyssa Milano
on Twitter and we're going to be talking
about China quite a bit we're going to
be talking about Disney but um this just
happened this morning on CNN
uh diversity is very important it is and
by that I mean it's not you know when
people say diversity is our strength
greatest strength it's it's no here's
the thing diversity is never your
greatest strength and sometimes it can
be a detriment now it's not always a
detriment but for example you know if
you look at combat units they're not
like everyone have ever lets everyone be
diverse Everyone Do Your Own Thing no
you have to be unified certainly as far
as ideas as far as missions so sometimes
diversity is not your strength and it
never seems to be your greatest strength
however
we have more diversity now and I will
say diversity is good for example like
at drinking fountains like at diners
voting in other words good things civil
rights act thank you Republicans but the
issue
is that not every place has equal
representation
now another sector uh has been resolved
and CNN is happy about this uh take a
look that is the New York Philharmonic
the oldest Symphony Orchestra in the U.S
and for the first time women outnumber
men in the group 45 to 44 it's a big
Leap Forward yeah and it's founding in
1842 when women were not allowed to join
at all here it comes the New York Times
reports that quote the orchestra's new
female majority could prove fleeting
though as it still has 16 vacancies
because of a hold on auditions during
the pandemic it's also important to note
that the New York Philharmonic is still
lacking when it comes to women holding
leadership positions quote the orchestra
has never had a female musical director
oh come on there's a glaring lack of
black and Latino members
this close I don't know if I by the way
I can say definitively that I speak for
all of us when I say I don't really give
a [ __ ]
German Shepherds fire hose is a drink
yes racism horrible slavery absolutely
bad black people absolutely should have
the right to vote Jim Crow South okay I
get all of it but now we're at Woodwinds
and also I think you could tell there
was a lack of black and Latino members
by the terrible music yes
there aren't enough black people playing
the clarinet no they come in and they're
like hey it's a black guy with a pan
flute and you're like tell them to leave
I don't understand what he knows what is
he doing here he's bringing in harmonica
if he's playing a steel guitar you know
playing some blues absolutely just like
if we want someone to play some kind of
metal in a minor chord we're gonna find
a white guy preferably a viking maybe an
Italian like Dio this is when you're
talking about you're talking about the
philharmon I assumed they were all Asian
because if they didn't make it their
parents would beat the crap out of them
with their trumpet yeah when the
Classics start including the bass riff
from my girl you'll see a lot more
diversity in the Philharmonic yeah you
also know it wasn't diverse the the
panel of people talking about it didn't
picture it was two women and Don Lemon
Nary a man to be found
they're underrepresented at the
Philharmonic sure okay I understand
right uh might I point your attention to
the top 40
.
there's uh good news there's no white
people to be friends yeah
kind of one of those areas
not only a meritocracy but uh you know
black people do really well with music
matter of fact they do really well with
white people with their music and this
is not new you go back to I mean you go
back to Eddie you go back to the
Supremes and go back to them you go back
to Johnny Mathis you go period go back
any point black people make better music
why because God favors them musically
yes sorry it's true
unless you have never heard of Motown or
you know Phil Spector who had to point
guns at people right but fairness they
were all black making the good music he
was just wearing the stupid wigs you
ever meet a black guy who can't sing No
it surprises nope yeah occasion I guess
I've met my friend Jeff yeah yeah well
like Kanye he tries to sing every now
and then in his songs and it's just like
it doesn't work rap singing is
inappropriate on every level yes it is
and I wish that every rapper would stop
yes I think that's they should join the
Philharmonic yeah
black people they make up a
disproportionate number of singers and
why because they happen to be good at it
okay Asians tend to make up a
disproportionate number of people who
are playing stringed instruments
Woodwinds brass they're very good and by
the way these are also areas we had you
know a choice sauce he was a
percussionist at NYU just let people do
what it is that they want to do also
notice that the seats are emptying
because they were holding back auditions
during the pandemic no it's because you
said no men need apply
yeah well biggie used to do rap battles
in Brooklyn on a street corner and they
were like who's this kid he wasn't
sitting there with a fiddle going at
somebody else
it's just not it it's just not part of
the culture who cares can we start a
movement for more white people in sports
yes well that would be racist though yes
I'm gonna be the same thing like I don't
care I just want to see a good football
game I could care less if the entire
team has no white representation it
doesn't matter to me there are only two
sports where there's more white
representation well obviously golf but
we're talking real sports hockey and
that's just because of cold climates and
then strongman competitions and that's
because naturally the Crazy Norwegian
and Eastern Europeans they just have
these maximal strength capabilities
genetically that nobody else has makes
sense and then tennis but then Venus and
Serena came by and they were like well
we're not good at this either yeah well
you know what they were ahead of the
curve on the trans Sports athletes let's
go to Milano
uh and her Tesla problem so Alyssa
Milano and you can comment below do you
feel like this is a big win
is your life more complete now
that there are more women in the
Philharmonic by one yeah but yeah by one
person and there's also 16 open seats
because no one wants to be in it right
so I'm just going to be a bunch of Ginny
hairy short men in the Rockettes I
wonder how ticket sales are doing yeah
they're very welcome the pandemic
they're like yeah that's why there's no
one here yeah yeah he's walking in like
look look at all the faces there are so
many women of color it's a Christmas
miracle
no it's a shitty Orchestra now just old
women and eight thousand dollar minks
that have been covered in red paint
since the 80s this is great
[Laughter]
all right so uh let's go here Alyssa
Milano crazy person uh and then also our
friends the Hodge twins this is a story
that was pretty funny I just really feel
like this encapsulates everything you
need to know about the Twitter meltdown
that's taking place uh now that Elon
Musk has taken over so there was an
exchange Milano tweeted this out Charmed
is where she's from for those who don't
remember yeah I remember oh yeah the
[ __ ] who's the boss oh that's true yeah
and then something else so Milano
tweeted uh out and see if he can spot
where it's um
hmm functionally [ __ ] I gave back my
Tesla right there I
nailed it hold on I gave that fantastic
I bought the VW EV I love it I'm not
sure how advertisers can buy space on
Twitter publicly traded companies
products being pushed in alignment with
hate and white supremacy doesn't seem to
be a winning business model and The
Hodgetwins nailed it they responded a
friends of the show
Volkswagen was literally founded by
Nazis and Hitler [ __ ]
yeah yeah
all kinds of notches
I saw that over the weekend and I was
crying laughing because I just read the
first part and I was like how stupid are
you then I saw that and I was like
excellent in her selfie she just blurs
the Hugo Boss yeah exactly her kids in
the Oshkosh behind her like oh don't
want that either I don't want that oh no
Elon responded with I just love that the
wealthiest man in the world is basically
like I said a 4chan autist he responded
with the 100 emoji and then a bunch of
crying and laughing faces
and here's the thing this is like I've
told you this before if you can't make
electric vehicles if Elon Musk cannot
make Tesla work in California the left
has no path to making EVS work it's not
about going electric although that can't
be done here in the next decade it's not
fee it's not possible certainly not
possible with exclusively Renewables
because you're going to have to charge
your car not to mention the fact that
the left has this war against nuclear
which creates zero carbon emissions but
if you can't make it work in California
and Elon Musk has to leave to Texas to
make the greenest
car company function at what point do
you say that your agenda is completely
useless and keep in mind I'll let people
like Alyssa Milano they all loved Elon
oh yeah loved him until they found out
that Elon by the way is not a white
supremacist just supports free speech so
these are some of the things that Alyssa
Milano tweeted out for Elon I am not too
long ago I am in awe of Elon Musk and I
continue to be amazed by my Tesla Motors
another one four people you'd want to
have dinner with dead or alive mine
Jesus Roberto Clemente John Lennon Elon
Musk
which is funny because it's similar to
my mine would have been Jesus Roberto
Duran John Lennon so I could slap a mini
Elon Musk yeah now she buys the only
electric car that still has an ashtray
don't forget the cigarette lighter by
the way I don't think that's how things
you owe money for work you can't just go
here take it back yes but you still owe
us money yeah oh no okay fine you paid
for it in cash here take it back
no any liberal that wants to do that if
you fully own your Tesla right now and
you just can't stomach holding on to it
and you want to give it back I'll take
it for free yes off your hands I don't
want you to be burdened with that yes
but she's also the same idiot that had
the crocheted mask
it looked like your your grandma knitted
an Afghan yeah like those crappy little
wool slippers that you would just use to
shock your brother yes and you're like
you can see your mouth and she's like
right but I mean it's the point of it
yes no no it's it's the gesture
no that's like that's like that's like
rolling on half a condom and being like
well I tried yes
or like you know putting in some some
breathing holes right like it's a
grasshopper and a mason jar yeah all
right you know I need a little air just
cutting off the tip here yeah
that's weird it's just yeah I'm not what
are you doing I'm cutting your birth
control in half to make it to stretch it
what do you want I'm a child of the
Great Depression yeah it's
the gesture waste nut waste not what not
now we've been following Elon musk's uh
sort of red pilling for quite some time
but we actually here now finally have
more photographic evidence he tweeted
this picture and I don't think it's Pi
uh I don't think it's happened stance
that he tweeted this it kind of admits
that Alyssa Milano controversy
controversy what am I saying stupidity
uh he tweeted this picture out with a
caption my bedside table see a bunch of
caffeine-free Diet Coke I don't know is
that a flare gun
I think it's a uh like a cosplay gun it
doesn't look like a 3D printed and a
pirate gun I mean baby steps it's the
George Washington flood lock yeah well
that should that shouldn't just be
sitting there and it's like is he
planning on using that for home defense
he's a billionaire where else did you
put it
safe he wants to wake up and look at him
put it in like you know like I don't
know shrink wrap it something it's got
the David Barton approach yes everything
out touching all the time yeah so that's
his bedside table and of course getting
in on the trend uh there are some other
uh celebrity bedside tables who tweeted
in response um well Alyssa Milano they
she showed her bedside table well that
makes sense new keys yeah oh I guess we
have some more here this just happened
recently this morning I guess uh former
Vice President Joe Biden tweeted out his
bedside table
Well normally it's just a picture that
says I am the President of the United
States he has to be reminded everything
someone did a little bit of
photoshopping yeah word of the day
calendar to make it more palatable yes
you should see his Advent calendar oh
boy oh boy uh another one I guess just
tweet out I guess this morning
Congressman Eric swalwell's bedside
table we now see
[Laughter]
[Music]
people listening on audio by the way
leave a review that helps but just just
go watch the video because this is a
live show Monday through Thursday it's
live nothing up our sleeves 10 a.m
Eastern you can watch it here on YouTube
you can watch it on Rumble right now if
you're watching on Rumble please if
you're on YouTube nothing would make me
happier than to see this number ticked
down on YouTube and the number go up on
Rumble like Ed Rooney's attendance
computer please head on over to rumble
and of course you can listen to audio uh
on on
today we'll actually have um uh
gingersnap come in because he actually
did his uh he did his I believe his
Masters I had a masters and I didn't
know he got it in China yeah
I don't even know this guy yes he does
he speaks Mandarin what he does yeah he
does fluently really yeah I mean maybe
he doesn't but to me he does yeah we
have no way of knowing yeah I guess I
can't prove it he would just say it like
yeah it sounds about right okay yeah I'd
be like yeah he made noises yeah it
don't sound American right I guess
you're trying it's unappealing yeah it
seems like I wouldn't want that it seems
like I wouldn't want to hear that you
know I wouldn't want to yell at me while
I was learning piano right all I said
was hi it's just very intense language
it sounds like something that I would
have heard shouted across the room at
the former Philharmonic
so before someone had piano keys jam
into their neck by an angry mother yeah
you missed
um
and a Disney uh and this also relates to
uh China because it's Disney uh they
have attempted of course to be woke of
finding the media by design by the by
the way this isn't an accident at a
certain point you have to say when all
the accidents for example or most of
them as they relate to voting issues
line up one way right okay how does that
always happen when when the media when
they're mistakes and covering stories
are falsely claiming that a story was
Russian propagate and it only leans one
way okay at a certain point where is it
a mistake the same thing where when
Disney they're only pushing an agenda
one way you never like Disney never
accidentally promotes a traditional
Christian nuclear family you'd think
like once it would happen by mistake
trying to think of any times they've
ever done it do you remember when white
people used to be in commercials
so anyway
I don't watch guys because I was
watching the Macy's Parade I never see
commercials and I'm sitting there like
there is like there's just no basic
heterosexual you know no it's like an
American like white couple everything it
doesn't it's I'm not saying it has to be
but just like not even one or two well
if it is it's like a white girl a black
guy and an Asian kid and you're like
what happened yes exactly so those two
made an Asian there's lots of
conversations happen Dave there's just a
Milkman who leans his head in from this
exactly
so the film from Disney strange world uh
and it's a gay teen romance wonderful
really uh it's also a climate change
commentary it's on track to not I know
you're saying like make a disappointing
100 million no lose is the 100 million
dollars oh boy cost them 100 million
dollars yes and I'm not even I'm not
even a math Philharmonic member you're
not nope how would you pitch that with
that budget and people are like yeah
that seems right yeah gay teen sex
romance and climate change give him all
the budget yeah everyone loves gay sex
and climate change yes especially at
Disney World especially tweens
yeah so what do you think kids love it's
flopped it's gonna cost them a hundred
million dollars and obviously we watched
a good portion of the film so that you
wouldn't have to but we have some clips
here when you see the film it's kind of
easy to understand why it hasn't done
well our son is on your ship what did
you say honey what do you say what did
she say she said your son is on our ship
dad
[Music]
apologies that my dad is so dead
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I will say the animation is hyper
realistic some of it really seems uh
very very true to life they just left
zemeckis in the dust they did he's got
nothing I I will say it's more much more
Frighteners yes yes exactly uh hit the
like button by the way if you guys are
happy to see this failure and you can
comment below because the YouTube
algorithm does not want you to find us
so smash the like button you can always
hit the rumble button if you're on
Rumble so here's why this is a win uh
the market has spoken and you know I've
talked about how boycotts don't always
necessarily work when it's just
boycotting a specific company but an
area where you can be pretty effective
with boycotting is consistent
consumption so like paying memberships
or films right these aren't Big Ticket
items so like boycotting for example
Tesla by returning your Tesla that's
silly yeah a stupid person would do that
a good way to boycott those when you
have no interest in something whatsoever
and you don't even know it exists it's
really just a maintenance site yeah
really how I do it it's well it's
incredibly effective because you just
keep doing what you're doing yeah and
you build some momentum with that you
just keeps liking the stuff you like and
don't try to get other people to like
you for liking stuff you don't like
exactly and that's a perfect segue
because you know who agrees with you
America ah let's compare some of the
recent Hollywood successes uh with the
Disney failure so Paramount Top Gun okay
yeah that made
1.45 billion almost 1.5 you know when
it's done it'll be close to two billion
dollars and it's worldwide box office
sales they're stock it increased right
before Top Gun came yeah during the
promo during the run-up when people saw
they were promoting this everybody was
like well that's gonna do well yes and
stock started shooting straight up yep
exactly and by the way it's not like
it's a conservative film it's just not
an anti-American film and also by the
way it was a good film it was a good
movie and it's it's a fun movie yeah and
it wasn't an it wasn't also anti it
wasn't all inclusive but it wasn't
anti-vet either it was just a movie and
I think it's a good apples apples
comparison here because you have Top Gun
it's a sequel yeah right it's a sequel
to some beloved characters if sort of
become American icons same thing with
Toy Story so in other words it's not
like we're just taking a film that has
no track record Top Gun okay 1.5 billion
dollars light year 200 million dollars
by comparison
and their stock price plummeted right
before the release of light year because
people saw it and said oh
yeah a lot of people didn't realize Tim
Allen wasn't in it right yeah they
didn't know they were Chris Evans okay
what but it's live voice it's completely
unnecessary like I would understand if
it was it was a flashback to teenage
Buzz Lightyear but it's Buzz Lightyear I
mean it's a toy it's the same age Buzz
Lightyear they just changed the voice
because they didn't like Tim Allen's
politics so uh to try and correct course
Disney now they brought back Bob Iger as
CEO about a year after retiring retiring
this Bob chapek I think is out don't
don't celebrate that just yet by the way
Iger was sort of the architect for the
woke uh kind of business model yeah it's
not like Disney has been nailing the
conservative market for a long time and
all of a sudden this guy comes in and
changes it they've been woke forever
they've been too busy nailing kids
on my part
so here's what happened
okay they failed and so what do they do
do they come up with new ideas do they
decide to correct course do they decide
to innovate did they drag out uh Walt
Disney's corpse next to the Nazi
paraphernalia no they decided you know
what hey Tim Allen we were wrong about
that and they gave him his own Santa
Claus series
I'm not even gonna put him in the movie
that he's famous for one of the roles
they're like yeah we need you back what
do you want me to do a movie we'd like a
lot of them like an entire series of
things perhaps entire series we'd like
10 movies yes that are about an hour
long a piece but it's really just one
film that we stretch out with a bunch of
filler that's the current business model
yeah pretty much I'm sorry about
canceling your show moving it to another
Network that whole thing right you know
it's like stranger things the last
season they're sitting there going like
okay so three episodes
you forgot the Freddy Krueger rip-off
and all the musical montages it's now
nine yes
should we stop making this now that the
kids are 47 yeah should we stop making
it that the kid who went to the uh what
is it the Down Under land whatever it's
called not upside down how dare you the
upside down should we stop making it now
that number 11 was it 11. should we stop
making now that 11 has menopause
yeah she's appearing in osteoporosis
commercials with Sally Field you're not
in hell those are hot flashes she's
she's eating yogurt to help her stay
regular with Jamie Lee Curtis The Twist
is that the monster is G Gordon Lydia
I just don't think this appeals to kids
no I don't think so either and why is
Tom Selleck selling reverse mortgages
something about rodeos I don't
understand was this actually filmed in
the 80s
all right so here let's move another win
uh and you can comment below if you've
watched any of these films I I I haven't
watched them I've watched a lot of crap
for you guys I just couldn't stomach it
this weekend I watched the Macy's parade
and that was enough with the pride we're
gonna come to that we're gonna cover
that tomorrow oh my gosh and the logo
the Legos thing we were talking and so
many fat stick twirlers there's one that
people miss that I have that I I filmed
it on my phone the quality is really low
but it is exactly how you would expect a
morbidly obese Ranger at to go at the
end of the Macy's brand the quality you
texted it to me and I was laughing he
texted it to everybody
hey guys look at this that's all that
Thanksgiving need okay I do wonder how
close she was to the McDonald's float
she just did a costume chat can I stand
over there so uh Thanksgiving break okay
so we there was a long break Anthony
fauci gave a speech that he's stepping
down from his position of director uh I
always forget uh the Nia ID I always
forget what does it stand for something
an infectious disease yeah Institute
whatever or something an infectious
disease is the point is it's all ball
bearings these days so let's see though
if in his speech you can spot the moment
where in trying to sound grandiose he
screws up to a way that is laughably
unintelligent what I've accomplished in
my 54 years at the NIH in my 38 years as
the Director of niaid
although covet is really really very
important
um it is a fragment of the total 40
years that I've been doing it so I'll
let other people judge the value or not
of my accomplishments what I would like
people to remember about what I've done
is that every day for all of those years
I've given it everything that I have and
I've never left anything on the field
[Music]
he's like I never left anything on the
field I always kind of half-assed it on
the field so I could save my zest for
the locker room
does he no you're supposed to you leave
you leave everything out there that's
the whole thing right you ever seen any
motivational speeches like I want you to
leave everything out there damn it it's
like oh okay we'll break ourselves for
you coach got it good he's like but you
know I just I gotta save some for
tomorrow
I don't want to run plays or make sure
you know I don't want to see how this
works you know I want everyone to know I
left a lot in the tank for the swim back
yes
you left dead beagles on the field we
know that for sure that's true piles of
them they weren't dead when I left him
well the Flies did their thing they were
being consumed and I let nature take its
course is the Fieldy coveted slash AIDS
graveyard you created yeah yeah yeah the
field of mediocre Dreams yeah he's like
how do I do this worse than I did before
with AIDS if you if you build it they
won't come yes exactly unless it's in
the bath house
Where I Leave a lot in the tank then
when I get back there I left everything
in the bath house none on the fields ew
he's wrong about and like no one just
asks him like Hey you know that's wrong
right you know that you're sounding like
the lazy prick you are that nobody wants
to be in charge of anything and so many
people out there on Twitter The Virtue
signaling oh thank you Dr fauci for
saving us I can't does anyone still
believe this this is a genuine question
that I have if you're out there right
now do you know anybody who still to
this day thinks that lockdowns and The
Mask mandates that these were a good
thing comment below I would love to see
your comment below
find it increasingly rare to meet those
people yeah they go well it's sort of
shifted right well we did the best with
the information that we had at the time
which is also untrue but people who just
full stop support what fauci did you
can't find those people anymore so I
consider this a win that he's gone of
course he'll be replaced by some other
Frankenstein monster but for the time
being Dr fauci I use that term loosely
it's time to close
Dr Anthony fauci is officially stepping
down I thought it was the right time he
has spent more than five decades working
in federal government you weren't too
masks isn't that theater John I don't
think we're going to see lockdowns
endings and beginnings
are ending in beginning now
I thought that the covet outbreak would
be over the NIH and niad
did not fund gain a function research to
be conducted at the Wuhan Institute a
proposal that was peer-reviewed and
given a very high rating for the
importance of why it should be done the
United States is stronger more resilient
and healthier because of him I know
that it's time for things to close
[Music]
he's going to live out his remaining
years on Temptation Island I'm sorry
that's a Fire Island
no so we talked about you said the best
information you had at the time I kid
you not we can probably pull this he was
doing kind of his farewell tour to the
media and was on one of the shows I
think it was like a CBS show and said
they were like hey with uh with schools
coming back in season I know it's winter
do you think we'll see any like you know
you might see lockdowns for kids closing
schools and yeah you know but that would
have to be done on a and I'm like are we
still talking about this like closing
down schools is still looking in your
mind like locking people down is still a
thing in here did you also hear us
answer about the Chinese cover-up was
like well there's a difference it's not
a cover-up just if they're not
transparent
yeah how about we just admit I don't
know you were wrong about everything
yeah uh people are still afraid so
they're wearing masks no because if I
admit my if I'm if I admit that I'm
wrong that'll be too close to admitting
to lying right I am the science because
you used othering and name calling and
division to get your thing to work is
that at all possible oh excuse me Mr
Monday Morning Quarterback yeah
I have a baseball card do you yeah I
remember when I was watching uh Chinese
people get uh you know what was it what
are they using to they're using like uh
guns yeah guns guns
yeah one of them triggered things yeah
yeah well when they were they were
basically what do you calling you they
were just making them stay in their
house by yeah they were like welding
them in welding the doors yeah they're
welding the door I was like that
probably isn't good that might come over
here to America yeah that was before I
even knew who [ __ ] she was yeah and
he's like they're doing a great job in
China and I'm very comfortable with them
mostly because they are my same height
that is neat and I want to thank uh I
want to thank the fan that gave me the
foxy baseball card this weekend did
someone actually yes is it the authentic
tops it's the authentic time holy crap
I'm very excited about it I wish kids
still collected baseball cards just
because like some kid would be trading
the like the the fouchy tops and every
other kid just would burn it
card is that how this game works it's
like the Joker in your deck you're just
like let me just get rid of it yeah it's
just the the limp person playing cards
we just meshed three things together
well so did he
he's such a piece of crap I just don't
understand why anybody was defending
still a piece of crap we've got the clip
I think now the ones I was talking about
a fauci saying that we could possibly be
closing schools again oh my God don't
listen to him coming out of the holidays
should parents expect schools to shut
down I don't know
um shut up Margaret I'm not sure I don't
know
exactly there's always the collateral
issues so you have to balance and you do
it in real time depending upon the viral
load of disease
upon the viral load of the disease in
your region we're gonna shut down and I
know we're on YouTube and so I have to
be careful we're going to shut down
schools just look up the data on how
covet has affected the school age group
don't that's all I said don't just look
up don't do it we'll get removed again
for citing actual statistics
I said do research there's no proof that
kids that stayed in schools that were
allowed to stay open and are far better
off not in the ones that whatsoever
there's no evidence this is why because
I want Hall monitors running your
country I'm sorry when people it's not
it shouldn't always just be safety this
is a guy who just he doesn't take into
account Freedom he doesn't take into
account negative consequences this is
this has been an exercise in removal of
freedoms in the name of safety and by
the way it was a Croc but you also
shouldn't have leaders only make
decisions based on safety that's not the
only consideration to take into account
fauci is proof positive all of the great
leaders
on whom you you look back throughout
history these were people who took risks
these were people who made some
unpopular decisions these were people
who were whether you look at Churchill
who by the way was ousted I think within
two years because he didn't socialize he
didn't want socialized health care right
you look at George Washington you look
at Abraham Lincoln take your pick none
of them were glorified Hall monitors
fauces should never be within Striking
Distance in a position of authority that
could actually lock down this country
he's not even elected think about how
much power it completely unelected
official who has worked in government
his entire life with no regard for the
Constitution think of how much of an
impact that little [ __ ] had on your life
pardon my language
but don't pardon my language I can't
think of anything more descriptive yeah
and by the way the people that bought
the fauci candles
[Laughter]
it's bad enough that there are candles
and I'm not a huge fan of burning
candles to Saints and all that stuff and
I understand some people be like oh
whatever it's not a big deal fine I'm
not even talking about that but fouchy
candles really isn't there isn't there a
line where it's like Thou shalt not
worship alive people at the very least
yeah exactly
come on well and you're really nice
Satan right exactly you're not supposed
to worship anybody but God and having a
candle to a guy it's just like this is
just beyond the pale this is incredibly
weird even if you're Levain Satan yeah
just it's not Johnny Cash which seems
passable no I'll allow it okay
menorahs too they make coffee menorahs
oh my gosh oh wow
[Applause]
why is that is that the vaccine give
unto us a king that's what people want
people want to be ruled people want to
it became such this is the thing with
covet it just became I am going to be
all in and I I am just begging I am
waiting for the next opportunity to
support an authoritarian regime and more
control over our lives for example when
you troll to the left and you stick it
to the left and people don't like it and
sometimes it's immature usually you
offend them by saying something not all
that offensive maybe it's making fun of
their diversity quotas or maybe you you
support freedom in one capacity or
another the left if they really want to
piss off the right it's they're going to
lock you in your house ah they're gonna
take your kids out of school they're
going to force you to get an mRNA
injection think about that there is a
huge difference between you know
engaging in playful trolling by pissing
off the left and supporting more freedom
freedom of speech versus your Mo your
modus operandi is removing someone
else's Freedom it's absolute totally
insane thank God fauci's gone speaking
of Freedom being removed you may kind of
you may have glanced at this and we want
to give you the ins and outs and explain
to you why this matters not only here in
the United States but also historically
and as far as international relations
look first let me set this up China and
Taiwan
um that's going to be the epicenter of
World War III if we run into that not
really Russia just I mean we've talked
about this I I I don't know there are a
lot here's the thing there are a lot of
Shifting Dynamics with Taiwan and with
China but right now in China if you
haven't been following this uh
Nationwide protests they've been
erupting in response to again the
government is now continuing and
reinforcing even more strict Draconian
coveted lockdowns a lot of the people
have had enough they're protesting
foreign
wiping the snowball from their eyes and
going okay all right they couldn't get
Taylor Swift tickets either no
master
is it Ticketmaster yeah I don't know now
these are the biggest uh protests since
the 89 Tiananmen Square massacre for
those of you who uh don't know they
started after
a fire in um I want to make sure I read
this correctly uh arumchi in xinjiang
right killed 10 people
um who were locked down so they were
killed by the fire because they were
locked down under the zero covid policy
I think we have um a clip to show you
[Music]
because you don't know these fires
they're residents the city has four
million people they have been barred
from leaving their home for 100 days
so they've been barred from leaving
their home for 100 days you have now 10
people dead at least 10 people at least
10 people we've heard higher numbers
right now and we know that they're not
going to release the actual data and
this part we don't know if it's true I
have no reason to believe that it's
untrue considering that this had been
done before some of these people may
have been welded into their Apartments
uh just as well Dave just discussed uh
had happened there's videos 2019 that
was happening it happened back then we
don't have a video of it happening right
now yes but there are some reports on
the ground saying that it did happen
again I have no reason to disbelieve it
because it did happen in uh in Chengdu
[Music]
thank you
so think about this first and this is
the nation that fauci praised repeatedly
they're doing a great job of bang-up and
he's still defending he'll say what
about the cover-up well there's not so
much a cover-up as not being transparent
you don't need conspiracies to
understand the cooperation of global
governments of national governments
becoming a One World Government they are
not in this not only do they not care
about you they don't care about their
own citizens we should once upon a time
once upon a time we would have been
fighting China we would have been at war
with China if they attempted to have any
influence in our society because we
understand that it's a corrupt communist
nation and they should have not some
zero influence this is a perfect example
where diversity is not our strength the
ideology of China anyone who comes from
China who supports CCP or even the
tenets of Communism is not welcome here
and of course our government should not
be advised in any capacity from any
members of the government in China yeah
for the reasons you see well and just
for people who are like oh I can't
believe they would do that if anybody
out there supported lockdowns that is
The Natural end of lockdowns that is the
only way that a lockdown actually works
by the way having Amazon packages
delivered having grocery stores open
having gas stations open having certain
places open is not a true lockdown it
just pisses you off and kills your
economy the only way to be effective is
to do that you literally lock people in
their homes by force if necessary at
gunpoint most of the time because if
they don't have enough food and die that
is the price you pay for a lockdown that
is truly a lockdown that's why we were
saying no no no no this is a bad idea
don't go this way one it won't work and
two you don't want it to work because if
it does that means people will die from
starvation in their homes yep no you're
absolutely right and by the way
everything is done at the end of a gun
with the IRS paying your taxes this is
why it's so silly when people say
they're they're true pacifist now I'm a
non-interventionist you can't be a
pacifist because you're only afforded
that luxury by living in a society that
of course to some degree lives under a
Perpetual threat of violence lock down
what happens if I don't lock down now
the good thing is you guys here and you
can go join up at loudest cutter.com we
did mug Club quarantine when the rest of
the country quarantined when even other
conservative shows they weren't on or
they were broadcasting from their
basement we started doing two a days
because we aren't beholding to anyone
else we're simply beholding to you
that's the beauty of actually being
independent but what if you don't pay
your taxes you walk it through what
happens people eventually with guns come
and take you to prison if you don't lock
down well you see exactly what happens
they weld you in your apartment they're
just a little bit further down the trail
and by the way so as Canada we'll get to
that comparison in just a second but in
Beijing he had crowds Gathering and they
were shouting out and this is a big deal
for China it is not a covet tests and
yes to Freedom here's a clip foreign
and it's just kind of sad because you
see they want their freedom but they're
still all out there wearing the masks
it's just it's just one of those things
where you watch like you're not quite
there yet but you're taking baby steps
well I mean it does take huge balls for
what they're doing exactly and that's
the thing is they're terrified and
they've also been brainwashed yep you
know so there's so many levels of it but
I mean I honestly have so much respect
for those people right now it's a
national it's it's a national movement
of breaking off from a cult absolutely
it is um so you have uh for example uh
also at qingwa University
um students they were shouting freedom
of expression rule of law so these
people don't want Anarchy uh but they
also want democracy here's a clip
and that matters because Xi Jinping and
the former president they went there
yeah they're alumni that's their alma
mater so and I think we're going to get
some information from uh gingersnap on
that is that his name still or yeah yeah
he went there he wanted to go with a
different name they went there that so
this is like the home the mecca of
basically the Chinese Communist party
yeah they were saying that kind of stuff
there and by the way it's not just the
Chinese government people will come and
take you away and kill you they could
very well do that we've seen videos they
all they have to do is turn off your
ability to participate in society and
they can do that with those social
credit scores the stuff that we've
covered before right giving you the
opportunity which they're trying to
incorporate here in the United States we
have a job anything like that all they
have to do is press a button and you're
done yeah that's it and these people
these people know that full well they're
not burning down a Walgreens that's you
know franchise owned by their neighbors
they know that they can be run over with
tanks they know that they they could
have a bullet in the back of their head
and the bill sent to their family and
they're deciding to protest anyway this
is a look into the crystal ball of what
the left would have here if left
completely unfettered with their power
unfetterman in which case they're too
far because the left doesn't realize
they've just become an extension of
authority yep it's like all you guys are
is pawns you're just pawns for Authority
who's going to take out everybody else
and it's like you said too it is very
easy to be passive when it doesn't
affect you right but believe me once it
affects you you're not going to be
passive anymore but look at the worst
Association that people like us have in
other words like I don't have a dog in
the foot we've talked about this with
the primaries I'll vote for someone as
an R next to them the most hated person
on the right Donald Trump okay so you
know someone by the friends they keep
sure I think you also can uh you also
can judge someone by the enemies that
they have but let's say Donald Trump is
the worst all right
you guys
the party that welds people into their
Apartments
the world economic Forum right if you
look at what they're actually the German
government is still also bad enough if
you look at what's happening with with
uh with Nate you look at what's
happening with the UN right if you just
look at the people you align yourself
with it's far worse than Donald Trump
claim to be compassionate but you don't
have a problem with a man who
disgustingly abuses animals right and
stop saying it's because of science it's
not acceptable look at what he does well
he hated Donald Trump right of course it
was very difficult with Donald Trump I
had a much easier time working with the
Chinese party hold on
could you keep it down I'm trying to do
your bidding yeah these numbers are
accurate right no coveted cases zero
right well good enough for me all right
too bad sandwiches please I'm going to
the states you've never lived until
you've had Xi Jinping bet loaf oh a
little bit of mustard Undead oh boy oh
boy I'm gonna throw a ball like yellow
mustard none of that yellow [ __ ] no
laughs
it's very dry you haven't excused me do
you have any gray poop and just punch
them in the face
and Shanghai protesters shouted uh to Xi
Jinping to keep in mind that says this
is an authoritarian communist who will
kill you and has no problem with that or
jail you protesters were shutting XI
xingping stepped down the Communist
Party you need to step down here's a
clip
[Applause]
and the only way this works is if it's
just a sheer numbers game oh yeah they
have to overwhelm we think that we're
Beyond this we think that we are Beyond
people overwhelming the government by
force when for example when people look
in Brazil they're like oh so you're
saying you want a military coup hold on
a second the context does matter if
people feel as though not only have
their elections but certainly in this
case they're very basic human rights
freedoms any form of Liberty have been
stolen from them there's nothing wrong
in that case with a coup if the coup is
if the coup is largely spurred on
because you're being welded into your
apartment yeah and here's actually a guy
I haven't seen this clip yet but we
pulled it in um he's getting I guess a
haircut and he let the cops have it
um
he's in a barber shop chair and he's
telling them we don't need you here to
the cops go home go home get out of here
and now there are people in there
clapping
Also let's add that that guy's in a
barber shop wearing a Beret yeah
weird fashion they really messed up my
hair they just take a little off the
side so I can wear Beret this is my new
thing maybe that's it they don't have
all have bowl cuts it's all Beret Cuts
I'm going to bring a beret back other
people like no no no you're not bring a
beret back it's not work the workers
stupid
I work at trendy no trendy look a [ __ ]
no no no no no no no no no no but hey no
no one
please please just take it off I thought
great Sam Kinison oh
OH police coming to wear me come back
it's a really weird several layers deep
yes but I was married for two years
[Laughter]
that's hilarious
so
God love him and by the way here's a
here's a guy who must have balls of
steel
China BB's uh started a chant he was
shouting the Patrick Henry slogan give
me I didn't even know that they knew
this and I don't know if I would not be
I would have no way of knowing that
they're even familiar with the slogan
the Give me liberty or give me death
[Music]
is a Superman backpack that's true which
he finds out that Superman's now gay oh
I think he's talking about the real one
his Buzz Light your underwear the one
with paralysis yes right paralysis how
in the world are these videos getting
out by the way one of the reasons we're
going through all of these from all
different parts of the country different
groups of people is to show you that
this is unprecedented in Chinese history
this is not like a single protest and
we'll talk about that in a minute but
how in the world are these things
getting out I know that there was a note
in there that maybe the internet service
is being cut in certain areas like the
government is trying to respond we're
not able to confirm all that yet so we
don't want to come I don't want to come
to you with information that we can't by
the way everything that we are reporting
for you right now uh all references are
available a lot of cutter.com you can
always go check them out Link in the
description yeah but they're controlling
the media yeah how in the world are
these things getting out I mean this is
one of the greatest reasons for you to
look at right now if you think that that
big Tech should be able to do whatever
they want to do it means that China's
videos would never get out right they
would never ever ever get out if there
is complete 100 control so obviously
somebody's doing something or are
sleeping yeah they're able to bypass it
somehow somehow which is fantastic
otherwise the world wouldn't know but
keep in mind these people are facing in
some instances certain death or being
arrested jailed for the rest of their
lives and they have decided that it is
enough and they're standing up what's
your excuse that you might lose your job
that you might be ostracized on Facebook
by your 75 year old Aunt with an immune
compromised system like what is your
excuse and by the way this has gotten so
darn now they're actually reports of
plain clothes officers going into now
rough-up protesters oh
come on
that's not cool that's not cool even
even scarier than that we have another
clip uh some of the authorities they've
started abusing and arresting and this
is always what happens right if you
control information we've talked about
this here when people say hey who do you
think will be the next uh Republican kit
it it's not that relevant to me if you
would pick the power
of Washington DC or even the White House
over the power of Hollywood over the
power of media and certainly big Tech I
think you absolutely need a CAT scan you
think Donald Trump was the most powerful
man he was removed some from society
with a snap of the fingers d-platform
that's why the Gatekeepers are so
important you have people now you have
these Tech oligarchs who are more
powerful than National governments and
by the way they are they they are the
the glue that bonds International
governments together who want to work
against their own citizens you're seeing
it right now in real time I cannot
stress you enough the gravity of this uh
they have uh right now if I'm not
mistaken I I don't have confirmation on
all of them but I do know that they've
been arresting foreign journalists and
we do know for sure that they've even
arrested one BBC reporter this is these
are authorities in China
now here's the thing is that terrible
sure but
let's also be clear we're several steps
in there of allowing your autonomy to be
removed short China is really bad I
understand that
but does the BBC reporter really have a
leg to stand on when it's BBC when it's
government funded news the same thing in
Canada CBC you can [ __ ] about corporate
media man sure what about when it's
government media and we'll get to Canada
in a second right these are steps that
take once the government takes over the
media then the government says you know
what we can we can now legislate hate
speech laws on Tech platforms that were
meant to be open
open platforms the digital Town Square
so yeah obviously I don't think this
person should be arrested by the Chinese
communist government but would that BBC
reporter support Americans would he
support us being de-platformed for
saying things that would never be
allowed on the BBC
it's incremental it's the frog and the
the pot of boiling water by the way hit
the like button right now to show some
support with the Chinese people because
uh you know that YouTube is not a fan of
this being covered what's also comparing
it's the government comparing China to
their own government right so it looks
less violating right that's all it
really is yeah at least we're not as bad
as those guys yeah at least we're not as
bad as those guys yeah we just yeah we
don't we don't well people into their
Apartments we just remove your ability
to make a living if you step off the
reservation and say something unpopular
that will label as hate speech well also
when was the last time you really had
Thanksgiving 2019
when you think about it like when was
the last time this actually felt like
America like it really felt like you
were going into Christmas I'd say
probably 2019. and it's because of what
you're looking at right now but now we
have 19 year olds saying how they're
going to get communism right right but
you can look at an entire know how to do
it nation of a billion people yeah
trying to break free from it okay who
did get it right well not sure I'm not
talking about well I'm not talking about
stalinist Russia oh I'm not talking
about leninism oh I'm talking about Mark
and what they end up going to is they
end up going to uh the catalonians uh
right for their sort of Revelation and
that's I think it was was it from 34 to
37 before they collapsed under the
pressure very publicly the Soviets
coming in uh it's one of the and like
it's anarcho syndic it's socialism this
is what they'll teach in college by the
way and it is absolutely absurd because
when that happened you just had factions
of socialists by the way marauding packs
of murderers killing other socialists
and it lasted like three and a half four
years if I'm off I'm only off by one
year I guarantee you it wasn't more than
five it has no that is the most
successful exam example of Socialism or
communism that people can point to I did
a segment on it years ago you can search
it on my club you can't search it on
YouTube because it's been memory hold so
why is this protest
unique and I think Gerald you can
probably uh so yeah so we actually had a
Cambridge Professor William Hurst he
actually said that there have been five
main kind of groups of contention in
China so in the United States we think
okay a protest kind of catches fire and
it spreads across the United States
because there's nothing really to stop
it and a lot of times people get out in
the streets look at BLM right nobody
would stop that even though they were
actually burning down businesses and
trying to kill people but they made a
lot of money and bought a lot of real
estate they said yes yes so typically
they kind of segment into like labor
rural students Urban governance or
systemic political dissent right or
systematic sorry so those are typically
the groups of protests and what you're
seeing right now they tend to be kind of
independent yes right groups so they
can't coordinate nearly as well and
especially when the government is
controlling media and they control
social media specifically they it makes
it much harder to kind of get together
they even control doors to your junior
suite apartment yes that's true welding
has that effect so it will do it right
what we're seeing right now is it's not
students in one place or it's not labor
people in another place it's not just
zero coveted measures in one place it is
all of these different places these
protests kind of sparking all over the
country and all of these different
groups come together that's what most
people don't realize that we've never
seen before in China and so that's why
it's different this time we don't know
necessarily where it's going to go right
there's some it could be the protest
could either fizzle out there could be
some kind of incredible repression from
the government there could be some kind
of concession from the government and
change because I'd rather do that than
go to war with their citizens uh I think
and you and I have talked about this we
think the the harsh kind of squashing of
the protest is one way that they'll go
maybe an overreaction and an
overreaction could involve Taiwan yeah
right if you feel like the country is
being viewed as Weak by the outside
world you've got these protests going on
all over the place and you're an
authoritarian regime what do you need to
do it's kind of like a Mafia Boss if
your viewed as weak you need to make
some big statement and this doesn't
matter something crazy yeah because in
Taiwan actually uh the for those who
don't like DPP the Democratic
Progressive Party and it doesn't
necessarily mean what you think it means
but in Taiwan
um they're uh this uh president
I don't know stepped down as a party
leader after a slew of local election
losses for that party the Democratic
Progressive Party the opposition party
the kmt I think is pronounced the KU
mintang uh that won a lot of mayoral
races including Taipei they're
traditionally surprisingly more
pro-china yeah so in other words they
could say hey there's some weakness and
maybe there's a time right now to
reunify but under our terms there are a
lot of Dynamics at play here that I
think people may be overlooking but what
could be the spark is the protests from
people across the country it's not just
one isolated group no no it's not one
isolated group and the Chinese
government to stay in power because you
don't just think about other countries
invading China you think about other
leaders within China right we watched
and I think it was the former prime
minister that was escorted away from the
table basically in that one video a few
weeks ago or a month ago that we saw a
month ago yeah they basically have to
it's kind of like this the The Game of
Thrones for them if they don't appear
strong within the party somebody from
within the party will eat them they will
be gone they will be taken out and a new
leader will be put in place so you can't
let protests go on forever you can't let
them run amok all over the country you
have to prove that you are strong in an
authoritarian regime yeah and so they
could take that step because they would
be like okay well somebody's going to
come after me same thing with Putin
Putin has to look strong to all of the
other people otherwise somebody will
oust Putin and also this is why feminism
has to die look let me explain you're
looking at this right now to the lens of
that could never happen that could never
happen here right right people go oh
that could never happen you're talking
about people men out there who are
willing to risk their lives is it
completely outside of the realm of
possibility that there could be some
kind of Guerrilla warfare by the way
that happens across the globe on a
regular basis this idea that women out
there and statistically it's not true
that they want a sensitive man they want
a man who is at home with the kids just
as much as them they want Mr Mom who's
changing the diapers and they don't
really want someone who is a Savage you
know who is an absolute no no no look
you are only a few meals away
only a few meals away from this country
being the road you don't understand how
quickly it can change and do you think
people right there now women who are
facing being welded into their
Apartments who can't leave to go get
formula for their babies do you think
that they want their husbands to be Mr
do you think they want them to be docile
no when push comes to shove women want
men to go out and do what men are
supposed to do and by the way that's the
cross we bear I'm not one of those men's
rights people saying well you you fight
your own battle I am perfectly happy to
do it just don't question the way in
which we do it you are four meals away
from needing that man to do what a man
has done throughout all of human history
and if you if you with your girlfriends
act as well that's not what you want
you're lying to yourselves and you might
only find out when it's too late I'm not
talking about a man who comes home and
starts swinging at you because you got
the you got the suit wrong I'm talking
about a man who might be a little bit
difficult to live with because he's got
a backbone those are the people who and
I'm sorry it's not feminists it's never
feminists it's never weak men those are
the people who are going to be the
Catalyst for change if people are no
longer going to be welded into their
apartments in China it's going to be
because of the men who've been pushed
aside as useless in modern society you
always want them unfortunately you might
reach a point where you call on them and
they're not there because you have bred
them out just be careful what you wish
for and here's something else I wanted
to talk about
what's happening in China just to drive
this home could never happen here in the
United States we think that we're
somehow beyond the idea of well War even
but certainly some kind of Civil War
certainly some kind of authoritarian
regime that needs to be stepped down or
certainly the infringement on our rights
that would be so extreme where we say
how when did this happen when did we
lose it except it basically did happen
in America light commonly known as
Canada with the trucker Convoy
Freedom this is for Freedom downtown
Ottawa the center still paralyzed police
putting up fencing around government
buildings around 400 trucks are still
here leaflets are being handed out
they're telling the truckers to leave
the area now or risk arrest and vehicle
seizures we've been bolstering our
resources developing clear plans and
preparing to take action you are why I
don't unilaterally with the unlawful
protesters we've told them they must
leave and we have warned them the
consequences of disobeying these rules
zip it what are the consequences
what are the consequences in Canada only
man allowed to have a gun
comment below if you remember and and
before I get into it we'll have all the
references available if you can see the
similarities between China and Canada
one's welding the apartment the other
one is you know putting the boot on your
truck which again is how you make a
living less severe sure
still pretty severe so let's actually
contrast and compare see where there are
similarities between what's happening in
China versus what happened in Canada so
let's go first to the Orient China
in case you thought it was getting too
serious authorities spare no expense
They seized millions in assets uh from
uh detained business owners right in
xinjiang okay that seems pretty severe
yeah yes let's go to Canada
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Trudeau froze the funds of the Convoy
protesters which by the way should be
absolutely that to me is reason enough
for revolution but the Canadians didn't
do it yeah in other words if you do not
Revolt When people's accounts are being
frozen and people are being arrested for
peacefully protesting I guess maybe when
they weld you into your apartment I
don't know I don't know what it takes
yeah you know the great sin they
committed was having a truck parked
downtown and honking occasionally yes
and that was Bank bank forfeiture
basically you just can't have any access
to money oh so you can't feed your
family or pay your bills or anything and
there's there are new developments that
are even worse again what would the left
do if completely unfettered what what
would China do the CCP if they had
absolute power I think you kind of know
because they sort of have
now they're being stepped back a little
bit what would Democrats do if they had
absolute power what would Trudeau do by
the way who is almost a deity for the
Democrats really their Saints are fouchy
and they light a scented candle from uh
from from [ __ ] doodle company for for
Trudeau Trudeau is all about power if
anybody thinks he's not you're
completely blind closest thing to him is
Whitmer in Mission absolutely 100 she is
the worst and she will run for president
she runs for president if she has a
majority you will have what you just saw
in Canada here in the United States we
are not that far off you are two
decisions away
from something this severe happening
here okay select home let's go back to
uh China okay so China they arrested and
they're threatening to arrest more
protesters
must delete or face arrest well how do
you arrest them what if they don't want
to be arrested
two people at the BBC detained I just
saw that in the yeah feel there not just
the one
but that's just off in a far away land
The Mystery of the Orient that couldn't
happen here in North America well hold
on a second let's go to Canada again
is there something comparable well you
have Trudeau's thugs they arrested
hundreds of Convoy protesters again
parking a car yeah and I don't I don't
think that I don't have a problem with
the cops because I think they're all
systemically racist I have a problem
with the police who enforce
unconstitutional laws right I have a
problem with the police who are willing
to use Force against their citizens who
don't comply so back the blue
unilaterally nope nope especially now
there are not enough good cops out there
and if there are you are not speaking
out enough certainly not in Canada so
let's go back to China we're giving you
an A B comparison here uh police
brutally assaulted citizens during the
2020 Hong Kong security law protest
here's a clip
what is she 80 pounds
good God in China that's considered
average that's right
it's just such an example of weakness
yeah just shooting people and that could
never and by the way we're not talking
about an a situation where a cop has
someone pulls a knife on them or or
someone reaches for the cops taser right
where you have to make difficult
decisions that's not lost I mean we're
talking about police beating up people
solely for the act of protesting yeah
now that of course is Extreme that's
about as Extreme as you get yeah they
were fine for not uh socially distancing
I don't know if you saw the little the
the letters there the reason this girl
was tackled
of this 12 year old girl that was such a
threat to your regime was tackled is
because she was too close to her brother
right and maybe a few other people in
the crowd potentially but it was
perfectly healthy to have four grown men
pile on her indeed like it was a Disney
audition yes exactly
Nickelodeon yeah sorry Nickelodeon yeah
yeah Dan Schneider Nick after show
naked night so this happened in China
that couldn't happen Canada obviously
isn't that severe let's go to Canada for
a second is there anything oh sorry
that's right police angrily beat Convoy
protesters right those were report there
were many reports of that and here's
something else this was recent news
it's just sort of it is bizarre that all
these things sort of the timing is is
lining up uh Trudeau's cabinet wanted to
use tanks on the protesters what yeah
Justice Minister David lametti texted uh
Public Safety Minister Marco Mendocino
saying you need to get the police to
move and the CAF if necessary then uh
Mendocino replied how many tanks are you
asking for and lametti answered I reckon
one will do
and uh by the way I don't know if you
know this this is something like you
shouldn't be surprised because there's
there's photographic evidence that
actually Trudeau did send a tank to
Edmonton we have a leaked image yeah
oh geez
[Music]
now here's the thing too there there
needs to be some accountability for
people on the right like Elon Musk for
example did support the Canadian
truckers at the time saying Canadian
truckers rule freedom is being Stripped
Away one piece at a time until it's gone
it hasn't said anything yet about what's
happening in China yeah this is one of
those things look if you're in charge of
Twitter right now and I get it there's a
lot of there's a lot of fun to be had on
Twitter it's not lost to me it is fun
well
what about China and this is the problem
this is why I'm not saying I'm not
saying that he's a bad actor I am saying
that it is tough when you are beholden
to other nations financially Tesla has
some major production in China
and I just I hope he comes out and says
something I think a lot of these
companies should come out and say
something right how many times NBA does
it take I know you're you're just
begging to be able to get in there and
all your shoes and clothes are made
there by children who can't barely eat
food by what you pay them but what does
it take for you guys to actually stand
up and say you know the people are more
important than our profits yeah all the
all of the entertainment industry Disney
included specifically all of these major
corporations that have production
facilities over there you guys have no
balls yeah
move your manufacturing move it to
Mexico United States can't somewhere
other than or you know what United
States will be the best or well not
necessarily sometimes made in America
means made American crap well yeah but
uh even if you still have your
manufacturing there well still speak out
against them and let the cards fall
where they miss which by the way way you
can send your email to tips.com we've
been looking for an American
manufacturer for mugs for years either
no one can meet capacity they don't have
the capability or even look into Taiwan
they more so specialize in advanced
chipsets we would love to have them 100
made in America they're etched they're
painted in the United States
but you don't hear me doing China's
bidding hey if they say we're not I will
not make my mug well then sorry you guys
are probably gonna get a crappier mug
that'll be a screen print that's the
best we can do in the United States
right now but don't allow yourself to be
muzzled because a huge component of your
company is financially dependent on
China there's nothing wrong with doing
some business or and by the way there
are some Chinese companies that create
unbelievably high quality products just
to be clear and there are some American
companies that create total utter dog
[ __ ] it's not lost on me
but that shouldn't change the fact that
the people in positions of power who
have the ability to make a difference
should be using their voices to make a
difference how much let me ask you this
and this is a you guys can comment below
and and please do share the show Tim you
can hit all the buttons as I'm talking
sharing hit the rumble button we're
going to have to go here
how many people out there you know this
Gerald about me specifically is I will
get with what we do here there's a lot
of work that goes on behind the scenes
it is not an easy job and I will get
beaten down and I will get exhausted and
I can make it really far with just a win
just a pat on the back it's like oh man
that's a wind under my sails and a lot
of people are out there that way a lot
of men you know if you guys comment
below you know how how touching is it to
you or how motivating is it when your
woman or someone you love or someone you
respect it gives you a pat on the back
it goes a long way right you feel
invigorated how much
of a wind
at their at their back do you think this
it would be for the Chinese people right
now if they felt like someone like Elon
Musk had their back
people like I mean whether it's Donald
Trump but people like Elon Musk or even
of course a long shot people like
Zuckerberg yeah right Disney hey what if
the NBA had their back
what if all the gay soccer players had
their back do you think that would push
them just a little bit more because
right now they're doing it on an empty
tank as far as approval as far as
support globally it would go a long way
and we have a and right now we have a
lot of people watching we have a lot of
people who support us I'm incredibly
grateful we try and use this platform
for as much good as we can do while
still remaining an entertainment program
but we can only do so much Elon how
about you do something I think you're
right well I mean I know you're right I
mean take a risk when it actually is a
risk now when you're going to whatever I
ran and you're wearing a rainbow flag
but you're also protected by everyone
there yeah it's something that actually
matters instead these people are these
people can die and probably will many of
them will many of them will many of them
will be beaten assaulted for what for
for wanting the same freedoms that we
have been pissing on for the last three
years yeah yeah and I'm not saying that
I support the idea of bringing over Mass
refugees okay so don't mistake me here
but what I am saying is
when we're talking we we qualify
everyone who's leaving whether it's
Mexico or coming through Mexico you know
from El Salvador Honduras
[ __ ] let me just [ __ ] countries as
they've been referred to commonly uh
they're not being persecuted they just
don't like living in a third world
country where there are no opportunities
we say well hold on a second these
people they're claiming Asylum they're
Asylum Seekers or we have refugees you
know uh military-aged Muslim men leaving
Syria right leaving Iraq right there
they come over and we had this Mass just
influx of refugees hey if you're go
where is the push for the left where's
Joe Biden right now where's the push
saying let's bring over as many of these
Chinese protests and I'm not saying that
I would support Mass migration but I am
saying at the left believes what they
claim to believe as far as supporting
people seeking Asylum refugees I would
certainly say that the people being
welded into their own Apartments have a
stronger claim to actually fleeing
persecution from their government than
someone who lives in a city in Mexico
that the government doesn't care where
they live or die it's just a crappy city
so in other words where's the left right
now where's the left talking about these
refugees and supporting them we see
their heart
for Ukraine money laundering capital of
the world we should what about the
people right now speaking out against
the Chinese government
and just saying hey we hope that there's
no violence we hope they can come to a
resolution isn't enough our leaders need
to if you're going to intervene in
Ukraine and Russia you certainly should
say yeah get them stick it to the CCP
like to see something like that do you
have any idea how invigorating that
would be to these people and instead
silence silence silence anyone who's
silent especially in a position of
leadership
hey look yeah I'm not going to say that
you should be ashamed of yourself
but I have no respect for you and you
know deep down in your quiet time when
you look in the mirror you have no
respect for yourself because there's no
reason to say nothing at this point and
it's unjustifiable share the show like
it we are going to go to my club and
actually speak with gingersnap yeah who
went to the same Alma Alma Mater as a Xi
Jinping wow yeah I know I don't even
know why he works here did we run a
background check YouTube piss off did we
run a background check
oh
foreign